I'm first and foremost a Christian and
that means not only that I draw my
inspiration of the Bible but also for me
I'm an orthodox christians so it's also
from the great Creed's the Apostles
Creed Nicene Creed and so on um and that
is a bedrock for my life I and I
wouldn't say that I'm a great Christian
the sense that I can always do what I
think I ought to do but I tend to I once
read a book by an Episcopal none yes
there are fiscal nods i watch her too
what sort of government Episcopal nun
who said that you can't see the future
and it's you can't tell what God wants
to do five years from now but if you
look carefully take the time you can
generally tell you're supposed to do
right now and I try to think of things
that way I try to think about what I
should do right now I tend to be a
thoughtful person I tend to be someone I
don't make snap judgments I like to take
time to think things over and then when
I make decisions I tend to stick to them
but they can be saved as I made over a
period of time we live in a world that
encourages snap judgments that rewards
thinking fast and I don't think that
makes for very good decision-making my
wife i should say is also a great
inspiration to me um my wife is not only
a christian but someone who tries to
live our faith and really thinks very
hard about the right thing to do she
currently has involved in issues that I
think are of great importance she's a
trained his lawyer his I am she's worth
Jones defenseman as well as being
corporate law before then she's now
affiliated with a couple of think tanks
and she's interested in the future of
mothering in America and in the world
and she's interested in the
commodification of children in two
senses both the the sense in which we
might say the commercialization of
childhood advertising aimed at children
trying to create little consumers and
also commodification a different sense
of the notion of designer babies and
what does that say about humanity about
us and about our future she doesn't go
into these things as a shrill advocate
she goes these things to try to
understand the direction we're moving
and try to encourage conversations about
these directions what I like about her
approach is exactly that that she wants
to encourage conversation when she wants
to do is create a world which people
think about issues and then talk about
them as opposed to go on television rant
and rave about them and that's kind of
work that I wish more advocates would do
its kind of work that I used to
hey